Stephen Sondheim is complicated and
complex and it's hard enough to convey
emotions through spoken dialogue so when
you add sometimes music and lyrics to
the process how do you tackle that as
actors you know in in some ways it's
it's daunting and his work is incredibly
difficult and complex but once you sort
of lay a foundation with his music it's
actually incredibly helpful you know
it's um it's like being guided
emotionally so um it never felt like oh
you know it's okay it's this part of the
song now and and like how you know how
do I perform this bit and it's all like
mapped out for you your emotional
journey is mapped out for you in in
melody and in that way it's actually
like if you just if you allow it to it
can help you so much so needless to say
it's it's complicated and it's hard to
learn but once you have it it's it just
completely informs your performance in
your character overall a lot of people
would say that into the woods at some
times most plenty at work and it's it's
it deals with a lot of issues they're
still relevant today but there's always
going to be a giant that we in the world
of people need to sort of down together
to overcome of one sort or another can
you speak to that that really doesn't
resonate with me at all quite honestly I
think for me it's way more about and the
was the whole idea that resonate that
these ideas are the whole idea about it
I think is that this is life that this
story tackles life's themes whether it's
now or thousands of years ago it's debt
it's the cycle of life birth destruction
death love sorrow shame guilt all of it
and it doesn't know really beautiful way
because you think our expectations going
in is that they will be resolved somehow
into this beautiful boat I'd kind of
gift of this is what life's about but he
doesn't do that it presents itself as
one thing and then completely dissolves
into this very
kind of existential moment at the end
with this newfound family going off and
you don't know what will happen because
it's been portrayed in this world that
many bad things do happen but that is
life and that is it's like I mean not to
get to not to pain too fine a point on
it but this is something that I've it's
almost like required watching for any
human being so children should see this
and I know oftentimes in high schools
the second act isn't seen but that's the
beauty of this piece is that in life bad
things will happen as well as the good
but you can always move forward with
hope and I think that kind of stories I
just think so important the first is act
is about wish fulfillment and the second
act is about how your characters that
the effect that your characters wishes
have on others right can you explain how
that relates to Cinderella and the
prince sums the your wishes effect of
the others right yeah I mean Cinderella
is actually a trickier one because um
yeah I was talking to someone from from
time and you know she was sort of saying
like whoa Cinderella isn't culpable in
the same way that the other characters
are but it's some because she she
doesn't sort of commit the same kind of
sins that the other characters do when
they are on their quests um because in
her nature she's she's kind-hearted and
that and you have to show that you have
to show that that's who she is but it's
about that when she is faced with um
difficult situations you know she
doesn't want to make a decision she
doesn't wanna make a hard decision
because sometimes you are in a position
where you have two choices
and somebody's gonna get hurt one way or
the other and to just stand and do
nothing is you know is not a decent
choice but it's you know she is along
with some of the other characters she's
paralyzed and you know it's it's
somebody like the witch who we think of
as a bad character it takes somebody
like her to say you have to make a
decision you know and live with those
consequences in other words is sort of
unique for a film of its
and scope because it was shot on
location and sound stages with practical
sets as opposed to CG and green-screen
how did that help your performances
working in the in the real environments
yeah the production design in this films
was extraordinary and we worked on a
soundstage that was made into a forest
and that for all intents and purposes
was a forest because the five steps a
thing and Hector yeah um I was really
quite something so it was very very
helpful to have that magic feeling
around as you were making you know film
Anna your Cinderella is not you sort of
touched on this a little bit your
Cinderella is not the stereotypical
persona for a fairytale character was
that something that attracted you to the
role well it's hard to say that the
qualities of Cinderella attracted me to
the role because just on its own Stephen
Sondheim would have made me want to do
it Rob Marshall wouldn't even want to do
it the cast would have made me want to
do it the music wouldn't me want to do
it and yes as it happens it's just an
incredible character she's so complex
she's so she's she's definitely flawed
yeah you know she she doesn't have the
same moral ambiguity at the beginning of
the film that some of the other
characters do but she's definitely
deeply flawed and indecisive and
overthinks things and and that was just
so much more fun to play with then then
some kind of very centered very pretty
very um sort of all-knowing and kind and
those are her only qualities kind of
princess um it was yeah just a just a
real blessing to play every shade of her
Chris just talk for a second about the
line I was raised to be charming not
sincere how does that basically inform
the character of the prince I mean
that's that that
the prince is the idea of what the
prince should be he's not a fully formed
human being he is everyone's conception
of the prince formed into one thing
metastasized and then given a huge
mirror and a camera and a 40-foot screen
to preen and that is his journey is that
whereas someone as being authentic like
Cinderella comes to a place of like what
do I want and she asked her prince what
do you want and what are you about and
why did you act this way he is a man
that is living out a story that's
already been pre-written and he doesn't
even realize it and even if he does
realize that he doesn't care because
there's comfort in that so he's not a
brave man you know and yet he's given
this wonderful opportunity when
Cinderella basically offers him this
chance of becoming conscious and aware
and fully formed and flawed and all of
that
he just can't quite do it yet Nene wants
to be the chivalrous shining Prince and
armor on a horseback and riding through
the force to save the day and he goes on
playing out that preconceived story but
there's nothing real about it but I also
think you can say that about I've met
plenty of people that whose that line
absolutely applies to and it's just a
reminder to of when you're you know even
doing something like this that you
always have the opportunity to open up
to someone else there's always that
chance to do that you know we put up
screens and that's great sometimes but
there's often times that other
opportunity like what are you about and
how did that make you feel and we're
living together in this world that you
know
you